bonjour et bienvenue pour cette option
sont aujourd'hui nous allons faire une
petite mise au point sur une notion qui
quand il s'agit de parler d'évolution et
cuisiné à toutes les sauces y compris
les plus nauséabondes
je veux parler bien sûr de la complexité
nos monde qui nous entoure est composé
d'une grande variété d'être vivant dans
certains sont dits simple et d'autres
complexes
dis moi c'est ce que vous disent les
profs la télé les médias le tout
internet et c'est la vie a d'abord été
simple puis elle est devenue complexe
tout le monde à chat est tout le monde
est d'accord ok on passe à autre chose
sauf que non ça ne marche pas comme ça
qu'appelle-t-on la complexité complexe
et par rapport à quoi
par rapport à nous et sur quels critères
l'adjectif complexe la casse en ce
comparatif
rien n'est complexe dans l'absolu les
engrenages et les rouages de cette
horloge son complexe du point de vue
mécanique mais du point de vue chimique
leur composition est bien plus simple et
monotone que celle de ce morceau de
granit car ils ne sont faits que d'une
très faible diversité d'atomes
métallique alors que le granit lui est
riche d'une grande variété d'atomes
l'un est effectivement plus complexe que
l'autre mais selon que le critère soit
la chimie ou la mécanique ce n'est pas
le même qu'il emporte la notion de
complexité et donc sans surprise
compliqué à cerner et on en attendait
pas moins d'elle
mais une fois n'est pas coutume
posons-nous d'abord les questions
faciles
d'où viendrait cette soi-disant
complexité la complexité vient de la
simplicité bien sûr est un exemple il
lui sera bien mieux cela qu'à long
discours prenons les colocations ou et
colocalisation c'est la capacité qu'ont
certaines espèces comme les chauves
souris ou les dauphins à se repérer
grâce à la production de sons très aigus
les ultrasons qu'ils produisent comme
avec un sonar ces animaux reconstitue
des images à partir des sons qu'ils
émettent en se basant sur la vitesse à
laquelle il est revenu et s'il a été
atténuée ou pas les chauves-souris ont
poussé cette adaptation à l'écholocation
à un point tel que certaines d'entre
elles sont ponctuellement capable
d'émettre puis de recevoir plus de 400
stimuli sonores par seconde
nous y sommes et perçoivent que 24
images par seconde ce qui veut dire que
le cerveau de ces chauves souris grâce à
l'écholocation de reconstituer 200 fois
plus d'image que le nôtre à tel degré de
précision mérite le respect et d'être
qualifié de complexe par rapport à notre
ouïe
plutôt basique pourtant il n'y a rien
ici qu'ils soient si différent de ce que
nous sommes nous mêmes capables de faire
faisons une petite expérience rien qu'on
sont sauvés vous devinez dans laquelle
de ces deux pièces vous aurez le plus de
chance de vous cogner leur taille contre
un meuble
celle ci ou celle là l'euphorie co2 la
première salle vous indique rien que par
sa réponse aux sons que nous avons
produit qu'elle est fort peu meublés et
ça c'est déjà de l'écholocation votre
oreille et votre cerveau sont
basiquement en mêmes que ceux d'une
chauve souris mais ne sont pas calibrés
pour les mêmes types de sons
ces différences se sont construites au
fil des millions d'années durant à
l'adaptation des chauves souris à
l'audition des ultrasons après que nous
ayons la l autre diverger de notre
ancêtre commun
il convient ici de digresser un petit
peu afin de bien mettre en évidence ce
qu'est un million d'années
napoléon l'hégire jésus jules césar
l'invention de l'écriture de
l'agriculture la grotte de lascaux la
sortie d'afrique la domestication du feu
l'homme de néandertal tout cela vous
semble bien loin n'est ce pas et bien
pourtant figurez vous que cela s'est
passé il y a moins d'un million d'années
beaucoup moins qu'un million d'années en
fait tout cela tient aisément dans moins
d'un demi million d'années le million
d'années est une mesure d'une grandeur
colossal qu'il est difficile
d'appréhender laissez-nous vous guider à
travers un petit calcul très simple qui
vous aidera à vous le représenter
admettons que la durée d'une vie humaine
soit 200 ans
c'est pas vrai mais sans les calculs
plus simple en vivant sans vie de cent
ans chacune pensez-vous atteindre un
million d'années
la réponse est non en vivant 160 ans
vous ne vivrez que dix mille ans c'est à
dire seulement un tout petit pour 109
millions d'années en fait il vous
faudrait vivre sans foi sans vie de cent
ans chacune pour commencer à voir
poindre à l'horizon le jour de votre
millionième anniversaire sans foi sans
vie de cent ans et vous n'en seriez
qu'au premier jour de votre premier
million d'années heureusement on
n'attend pas la fin de notre vie pour
nous reproduire admettons donc qu'on ne
prenne pas son temps comme unité de
mesure mais vingt ans c'est à dire le
temps approximatif d'une génération une
génération tous les vingt ans c'est un
peu sous-estimé car comme chacun s'en
doute bien deux ancêtres n'avaient
certainement pas autant de patience
en sortant il y a donc cinq générations
qui se succèdent ce qui représente 50
mille générations en un million d'années
on sait que deux individus séparés par
une génération une mère et son fils par
exemple différents l'un de l'autre
d'entre 30 et sans mutation
arrondissement
cinquante encore une fois pour
simplifier on obtient donc que durant un
million d'années se produisent environ
deux millions cinq cent mille mutation
donc si on ne suis qu'une seule ligne et
d'être humains
en cinquante mille générations il ya 2,5
millions de mutations possibles et il ne
s'agit là que des mutations viable pas
celles qui ne marchent pas bon après
comme il n'existe que quatre différentes
possibilités de mutations de l'adn atc
où j'ai que certaines mutations handed
synonyme sont sans effets particuliers
et que celles ci sont généralement
concentrés dans des régions bien
précises génome évidemment cela limite
beaucoup l'impact de ces mutations
néanmoins il s'agit tout de même d'un
gigantesque potentiel évolutif et il ne
s'agit ici que du tout derniers millions
d'années de notre évolution
tout ce potentiel ne nous fait donc
remonté qu'à l'époque d'homo erectus
donc pas si loin que ça en fait car la
vie elle n'a pas une histoire de 1,2 10
cents ou même 1000 millions d'années
mais 4000 millions d'années et la
plupart des êtres vivants sur terre non
pas des générations espacées de 20 ans
en fait
rares sont celles où elle dépasse un an
mais trêve de digression l'essentiel à
retenir c'est que ni le temps ni la trop
souvent invoquée rareté des mutations
viable me sont un frein à l'évolution
même avec des calculs basique arrondi à
l'extrême est ce pas du tout à notre
avantage et le tout sur une espèce ayant
l'un des temps entre générations le plus
long tout indique que même le genre
humain constitue un terreau fertile
développement d'une grande complexité de
n'importe quel organe un seul millions
d'années représente plus de mutations
qu'il n'en faut pour qu'un organe dit
sable évolué vers n'importe quel type de
complexité mais intéressant donc
maintenant à une deuxième question
simple l'évolution va t'elle vraiment
toujours vers plus de complexité et
croyez bien que si on s'y intéresse
c'est qu'il y a de quoi se poser la
question car cité les cas alors on
devrait voir émerger une vérité simple
et parfaitement observable lors de
chaque extinction qui a eu lieu par le
passé les organismes les plus simples
conduit s'éteindre en faveur des
organismes les plus complexes mais
franchement qui osera dire que le
biotope dédia carats étaient moins
complexe que celui de burgès qui aura
l'audace de déclarer que anomalocaris
est moins complet que ce qu'un requin
qui se paiera le culot de vouloir me
faire croire que tyrannosaurus rex était
moins complexes qu'une boule
si on prend le cas particulier des
extinctions de masse cela devient tout à
fait éloquent
on a trop tendance à vouloir simplifier
une extinction de masse
seulement trois étapes existe dans un
écosystème primitif extraction puis
développement d'un nouvel écosystème -
primitif mais ce qui se passe lors d'une
grande crise biologique n'est pas si
simple que ça en réalité tout part d'un
biotope très diversifiée à l'aise dans
son environnement
mais les conditions de cet environnement
change est sont perturbées par un
événement plus ou moins rapide à
l'échelle des temps géologiques
on vous renvoie notre petite digression
sur la valeur d'un million d'années sa
zone de confort perturber ce biotope
fini par disparaître
mais l'installation d'un nouveau biotope
passera par plusieurs étapes d'abord
l'apparition ou la prolifération
d'espèces dites opportunistes des
profiteurs de crise en quelque sorte
qu'ils adorent les biotopes perturbé je
vous vous demandez à quoi ces espèces
soit bien ressembler comment c'est
possible de sueur qui fait des crises
était à constater par vous-même que nous
sommes de plain pied dans une sixième
grande crise d'extinction et quelles
sont les espèces qui prolifèrent les
rats les souris les chats les tortues de
floride les frelons asiatiques les
méduses et nous les espèces ne se
rendent pas compte de ce qu'elles font
elles le font et c'est tout nous y
compris ces opportunistes de crise
peuvent coexister avec plus ou moins de
survivants va suivre ensuite une période
dite de radiation adaptative ou ceux qui
restent d'espèces envie se diversifie et
donne naissance à de nouvelles espèces
en effet lors de la crise des places
d'occuper est verrouillé jusqu'à leur
part des espèces hyper spécialisés se
sont ouvertes à la concurrence et
peuvent désormais être conquise par de
nouveaux candidats
les opportunistes pour la plupart
s'éteignent la phase de radiation peut
durer très longtemps et voir se succéder
de nombreuses espèces qui vont
apparaître croître et disparaître très
vite jusqu'à ce qu'un nouveau biotope
stable se met en place
les espèces se re spécialise les
écosystèmes se reverront y la course aux
armements reprend de plus belle
maintenant vous avez une image un peu
plus complète de ce qui se passe durant
une crise
et si vous trouviez cela trop simple
considérer le fait qu'il faut prendre en
compte l'existence de ce qu'on appelle
les lignes et fantômes c'est à dire
l'existence des ancêtres de certaines
espèces appartenant au nouveau biotope
stable dont on sait qu'elles ne sont pas
sortis de nulle part mais dont on n'a
pas encore retrouvé dans cette fosse il
il faut bien mettre que de télé
son prêt exister à la crise et l'on
traverse et même si on sait ni où ni
comment
voilà là vous avez tout le tableau et
même une fois le biotope stabiliser
n'allez pas croire qu il ne se passe
plus rien il s'agit d'un équilibre
dynamique un système au bord du chaos
quand une place est libre dans un
écosystème
elle est généralement occupés d'abord
par un organisme généraliste puis soit
ce généraliste se spécialise soit il est
remplacé par une espèce mieux adapté à
ce milieu au fil du temps les espèces
généralistes seront repoussés sans cesse
plus loin de la meilleure place tandis
que des espèces très spécialisés
prendront le pas les espèces n'ont donc
que le choix de se spécialiser de s'en
aller ou de disparaître
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que rien ne
reste gentiment sans bouger tout cela
tourne bouge et évolue sans cesse
ainsi ce qu'on appelle la complexité
n'est bien souvent au final qu'une
affaire de spécialisation plus une
espèce se spécialise dans une tâche un
comportement ou l'utilisation d'un
organe plus elle sera complexe de ce
point de vue mais n'oubliez pas qu'en
temps de crise la spécialisation est
pénalisé être trop dépendant de sa zone
de confort est un handicap quand
l'environnement via a changé si la
spécialisation et la complexité alors il
est certain qu'elle n'était pas
augmenter à l'infini en tout cas pas
dans un monde aussi changeant que le
nôtre les nombreuses espèces de poissons
récifal en font en ce moment les vrais
chacune est hyper spécialisés à une
petite partie du récif qui si elle vient
à disparaître emporte avec elle toute la
biodiversité qui lui est associé et ce
n'est pas le seul cas où la complexité
recul
l'exemple de la simplification des
parasites est particulièrement éloquent
à cet égard la cycline qui vit un
parasite des crabes est elle aussi un
crustacé comme le montre son stade
larvaire
mais en devenant adulte elle se
transforme en énorme sac ne contenant
plus que le strict nécessaire pas à
boire ni à manger
non la nutrition est assurée par l'exil
aux hits et qu'elle développe à
l'intérieur du crabe le strict
nécessaire c'est bien sûr les gonades
l'aca culine adulte n'est qu'un gros
sacs séminal tout juste bons à ne
produire que des cellules reproductrices
et voici le diable de mer et le vert
sont bidons les mâles qui vivent
parasites de la femelle ne sont plus que
de toutes petites enveloppes remplies en
majeure partie par leurs testicules
oui le mal de ces espèces a autrefois
ressembler à autre chose qu'une paire de
testicules mais c'était il ya longtemps
alors non la complexité ce n'est pas
toujours la voie royale
mais pourquoi qu'est ce qui freinerait
la sélection naturelle dans une course
effrénée vers plus de perfectionnement
de petites retouches et d'ajustement
sans cesse plus minutieux primeau et la
complexité coûte cher c'est là son
moindre défaut construire entretenir et
faire tourner une énorme usine à gaz est
toujours plus difficile qu'avec un petit
bout et sans prétention sa demande de
l'organisation et beaucoup d'énergie et
si l'évolution de la vie et aller
toujours vers plus de complexité
alors il va falloir m'expliquer pourquoi
les animaux qui domine notre planète par
leur nombre les insectes ne sont pas
ceux qui ont le système nerveux le plus
élaboré alors là je suis pas d'accord ce
sont pas les insectes qui domine
réellement le monde mais les bactéries
et les végétaux et où ils ont même pas
de système nerveux du tout de plus plus
une structure est complexe plus elle est
fragile ce cerveau dont nous sommes si
fiers est une structure très délicate et
sauf quelques exceptions notables il
devient inutilisable moindre petit bobo
et puis d'ailleurs le fait de ne pas
avoir un cerveau comme le nôtre ne
dispense pas quelques espèces comme les
pieuvres et les fourmis deux montré une
très grande complexité comportementale
donc non complexe n'est pas toujours
mieux ni plus efficaces et non la
complexité ne remplacera pas toujours la
simplicité non plus la complexité
résulte d'une histoire évolutive
particulière aux organismes et en aucun
cas elle n'apporte un bénéfice absolue
et comme on l'a vu plus haut elle peut
me mettre délétère bon alors c'est bien
gentil tout ça mais il faudrait arrêter
de se moquer du monde
depuis tout à l'heure la définition de
la complexité elle fait girouette un
coup c'est la spécialisation and
ecosystem un autre c'est la structure du
cerveau au début c'était d'entendre les
ultrasons faudrait savoir de quoi on
parle on veut dire quoi quand on parle
de complexité et c'est exactement la
question qu'il faut nous poser la
troisième et dernière question la plus
simple à formuler certes mais finalement
la moins évidente mais au fait c'est
quoi dont la complexité contentons par
complexité existe-t-il une mesure
objective de cette complexité
en d'autres termes est il possible de
pointer du doigt un attribut des espèces
permettant de dire à coup sûr et sans
critique possible de tels espaces est
plus complexe que tel autre
peut-on réellement classés par ordre de
complexité sans être arbitraire la
possession d'un cerveau nom vient d'en
parler et en plus prendre juste un
organe ça veut rien dire il ne lui
viendrait pas à les
comparé à une cigale à la lumière de la
bête charnière de notre coudes quand on
voit la brillante complexité de
l'engrenage des pâtes de la cigale bossu
sera pas résorbé le cerveau tout seul ça
marche pas bon bah en comptant le nombre
de nos cellules
pourquoi pas mais personnellement la
machinerie cellulaire d'un organisme
donc une seule cellule est capable de
faire la même chose que tout les
milliards de cellules de notre corps
réunis ça m'inspire plus de respect que
de piquer - bombe à la différenciation
des cellules ça on a beaucoup de
cellules mais ce ne sont pas toutes les
mêmes
oui il ya des neurones des cellules du
foie du pancréas des globules rouges des
globules blancs a donc on est d'accord
alors voici une magnifique courbe
montrant le nombre de types cellulaires
différent par rapport au temps en
millions d'années on voit bien que plus
les espèces sont évoluer plus la
différenciation cellulaire a augmenté
c'est bien de l'accroissement de
complexité ça okami les mignons et naïs
julie graff
dis moi tu vois aucun problème là où
j'ai un problème
battez organismes et sur le graphe sont
des faux cils bah non il n'y a pas de
cellule préserver sur les fossiles comme
on aurait pu faire ce graphe avec un
fossile a donc là il ya que des espèces
actuelles bah oui si on change les
espèces actuelles évidemment que c'est
des espèces qui vivent aujourd'hui s'il
en a ah ah oui ah bah oui là du coup je
vois le problème
bah oui les dates en millions d'amis
elles sortent d'où si toutes ces espèces
sont des espèces actuelles qui a décidé
que pop le poisson on va dire qu'il a
400 millions d'années un parce que bon
parce que vous êtes la poiscaille et
puis le crustacé on va dire qu'il à
100-150 m'ignorer ring parce que bon
parce que yolo hamas ah bah oui alors
ben toutes les espèces elles devraient
être au même niveau alors à 0 millions
d'années l'homme c'est pas la seule
espèce vivante sur terre aujourd'hui
non mais non mais non je sais je sais en
fait ce sont les âges de divergence
l'époque à laquelle leurs lignes et à
eux se sont séparés de notre ligne est à
nous donc en fait c'est bon en fait ça
ça marche mais non mais non ça marche
pas à regarde si ça avait été une éponge
qui avait fait ce graphe alors elle se
serait mise ou ton avis
à droite de l'image parce que c'est elle
qui a fait l'image
alors forcément elle va pas faire comme
si elle était moins évoluée 1 et puis
alors il dit bon par la date à laquelle
les lignes et menant à l'épongé à
l'homme se sont séparés ces 600 millions
d'années alors hop voilà ah ben je vois
est alors du coup elle en aurait
brillamment et scientifiquement conclu
que la complexité a diminué au fil de
l'évolution
donc maintenant tu vois tout ce graphe
transpire un raisonnement nauséabond du
genre il ya des espèces plus évoluée que
d'autres tout ça tout ça
là on est en plein dedans tu pars du
fait que c'est un humain qu'a fait ce
grave est qu en tant qu'humain il s'est
d'emblée attribué la bonne place bon bah
je me décourage pas et je lance compter
le nombre de gènes bien essayé mais la
daphné ou puce d'eau possède 31 villes
gènes soit presque dix mille de plus
comme au sapiens alors prends ce dec
taille du génome dans les normes
tu pourrais pas être plus à côté de la
plaque c'est en fait une amibe un petit
êtres unicellulaires qui possède le plus
grand génome du monde avec 670 milliards
de paires de base chez les plantes on
alla paris japonica et ses 150 milliards
de paires de bases et l'homme lui avec
seulement trois milliards de paires de
base voilà je suis juste déçu quand même
là je pensais qu'on était un peu plus
complexe que ça quoi ouais mais bon en
même temps comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure plus complexe et pas forcément
mieux
regarde notre génome il ya plein de
jeunes de bactéries notamment ceux
venant de nos mitochondries y en a qui
viennent de virus comme celui de l'ass
un sit in de notre placenta et y en a
même deux plantes beaucoup d'autres
jeunes ne sont que des copies d'autres
gènes et c'est sans compter qu'une
immense majorité de notre adn jusqu'à
preuve du contraire ne servirait à rien
a alors on a moins la dn qui sert à rien
je savais qu'on était les plus évolués
celle là tu l'as points mérités alors
déjà les oiseaux en moins d'adr non
codants que nous et en plus une
comprends toujours pas que depuis tout à
l'heure tu essaies de proue et que
l'homme est au sommet de l'évolution
on cherche pas tu y arriveras pas
l'évolution n'a pas de sommeil tous les
êtres vivants ont évolué durant le même
intervalle de temps depuis notre dernier
ancêtre commun à tous c'est pour ça que
raisonner sur la complexité ne marche
pas c'est parce qu'en tant qu'humain
nous cherchons nous mêmes à nous
valoriser par rapport aux autres espèces
la complexité n'est pas absolue elle est
relatif à un élément de comparaison que
nous choisissons en général cet élément
de comparaison étant choisie par nous
mêmes
les deux telle sorte qu'il met nos
propres attribuant valeur il ne nous
viendrait pas à l'esprit de comparer
l'inanité de notre peau au dynamisme
mimétique de celle d'une sèche ou bien
de fanfaronner devant un râteau tenue on
vous moquant de leur immunité contre
certaines formes de cancer non on ne se
compare aux autres êtres vivants qu'à la
lumière des caractéristiques qui nous
arrange
en conclusion l'emploi du mot complexe
quand on parle d'évolution créer la
confusion
rien est complexe par nature ni les
rouages d'une horloge denis le patron de
tâches du guépard une qui d'ailleurs est
le résultat d'un mécanisme morpho
génétique
étonnamment simple en réalité mais on
vous explique c'est dans une autre vidéo
chacun peut avoir dans la tête une
définition différente de la notion de
complexité alors que vous soyez citoyens
enseignants ou journaliste plutôt que
d'employer le mot complexe quand il vous
vient à l'esprit essayez donc plutôt de
le remplacer par la véritable définition
qui se cache derrière le cerveau humain
est plus complexe que celui des autres
animaux non expliqué complètement ce que
vous voulez dire le fonctionnement du
cerveau humain fait intervenir plus de
connexion et de neurones que chez les
autres animaux l'homme est plus complexe
qu'une bactérie
non le corps humain est fait d'un plus
grand nombre de cellules et d'une plus
grande diversité de types cellulaires
qui nécessite une coordination par un
système nerveux
ok nous ne sommes plus complexes de ce
point de vue là mais au moins cela
n'implique pas que tout notre être
serait au sommet d'une hiérarchie de la
complexité
vous verrez que ça mettra vos pensées au
clair dans votre propre tête comme dans
celle de ceux à qui vous vous adressez
et en plus vous ne pouvez pas vous
tromper et l' avantage c'est que si vous
tombez sur quelqu'un qui abuse un peu
trop de la notion de complexité vous
pourrez lui demander de préciser le fond
de sa pensée et peut-être alors je vous
rendrez compte qu'il n'a aucune idée de
ce dont il parle expliqué la définition
que cache votre emploi du mot complexe
mettez des mots sur ce que vous voulez
dire plutôt que d'employer des formules
toutes faites comme plus évolué ou plus
perfectionnés et vous verrez que très
rapidement vous emploierez plus jamais
ses mots car ils sont vides de sens car
si vous êtes du genre à affirmer qu'il
ya des espèces plus évoluée que d'autres
alors vous serez certainement d'accord
avec l'idée que les espèces vivantes
aujourd'hui ont évolué pendant plus de
temps que n'importe quelle espèce
fossile normal puisqu'elles se sont
éteintes
elles ont arrêté d'évoluer logique et
dans ce cas il vous faudra bien admettre
qu'une bactérie e
et plus évolué qu'à tyrannosaurus rex
c'est important les définitions
n'oubliez jamais de les formuler à haute
voix il ya un autre truc qui va falloir
qu'on explique à jour c'est la
définition du mot ancêtres non mais
attends regarde ça dans cet article il
parle de nos ancêtres les dinosaures
non mais ils sont sérieux là alors à ce
jeu là moi dans ce cas je peux dire que
louis xiv et moment s'être et puis
dorénavant j'exige qu'on m'appelle votre
majesté votre majesté ferait bien de se
renseigner sur ce que veut dire le
moment c'est être à l'heure à bah oui tu
as raison je vais aller chercher sur
internet commencent plus tôt par aurait
un dictionnaire des penan